I think they've made a really strong
outreach they both have a friends of
mine who are working on both the
campaigns and actually you know friends
of mine who are working on John McCain's
campaign as well perhaps not as visibly
and is openly courting the the gay vote
as the Obama and Clinton campaigns are
but because of history and relationships
and so forth I think there are there are
gay people who are involved with all the
campaigns some more closeted than others
and I think there they all have the
opportunity to do a lot of good no
matter who gets elected they're all
going to approach it in different ways
they're going to have different ways of
moving towards things but they all have
an opportunity I think to do really
really well and certainly the Democratic
nominee whoever that is will enjoy the
vast amount of support from the LGBT
community I think that goes without
saying and quite honestly appropriately
so given the support that the the
Democratic nominees are providing to the
community
you